also sorry für dieses schlechte filme
aber ich kann sich besser
[Musik]
leute das geht ganz kurz bevor es
losgeht ich habe das eigentlich schon
also das video schon länger fertig muss
nun erst nachträglich noch mal den
anfang machen damit die alles versteht
auf jeden fall habe ich letztens
irgendwann mal so ein video gesehen in
amerika da ist ein typ einfach die ganze
zeit im auto her gefahren also setzte
ich einfach ein autor ausgewählt was
gerade um pferd und ist die ganze zeit
hinterher gefahren und hat dann einfach
gefilmt was passiert gleich als ja auch
der eine oder andere von euch gesehen
gleicht daher ob jetzt weg ist oder
nicht war mir dann egal ich fand nur die
idee eigentlich ganz cool und habe mir
gedacht was passiert wenn man einfach
irgendwie sondern fremden ein tag
verfolgt oder zumindest ein stück des
tages verfolgt und genau das haben wir
heute gemacht also das video startet
direkt gleich wo wir fast schon wie ein
gefunden haben weil sonst wird es
einfach viel zu lange also dass nur
kurze erklärung ich wünsche euch viel
spaß wenn er sagt mach das nochmal
lassen nach oben da und es war wirklich
ganz interessant also wir schauen was
ihr später sagt letz okay leute wir sind
jetzt schon ein bisschen unterwegs ich
bin jetzt ein bisschen abseits gefahren
weil wir immer noch jemanden suchen wo
man halt ich weiß nicht das ist das
dumme ja wenn man halt einfach
irgendjemanden findet und der halt dann
so nach hause fährt oder so weil das
macht ja nicht so sinn weil keine ahnung
inhaber
ich weiß nicht also ich will irgendwo
hin wo man so denkt okay was macht die
soll was macht dieser mensch weißt du
weil ich habe
ich habe schon oft so dass ich so leute
irgendwo see und mir denke was machen
die da so gut da da zum beispiel gemacht
werde
vielleicht seine drin was macht das ist
so genau nehmen eigentlich hier also
also natürlich kann aber dieser typ da
ist da drin glaub ich nun zu dass wir so
ein abwasserwerk oder so leute ich habe
ja schon gesagt wie ich auf die idee
gekommen bin ich weiß nich so ich bin
also natürlich ist das nicht so mein
standard content aber ich wollte es
einfach machen und ht langeweile ich
habe meinen klausuren alle gestiegen
deswegen ist das richtig
denn komme
das wären solche reinfahren besteht an
liebevoll kommt sowas nicht mehr also
so was macht er da wieder papa mama komm
wieder park
bitte hallt noch kurz zu fassen es kann
ja immer sein dass die hat mit ihrem
hund spazieren so das machen ja die
meisten aber dann parkt man noch nicht
hier oder sollen wir können jetzt also
ich weiß ich wir können ja er kommt
zurück
warum ein armes auto okay leute wir sind
jetzt wirklich also hier ist wirklich
nicht so das gute ist man kein run xoom
also ich jetzt schon ganz gut was meinst
du aus welcher richtung kommt er aber
einfach aus dem wald oder was wie dumm
also ich würde sagen wie lange wir jetzt
also weiß darin zu lange dauert müssen
wir also wir warten hier ist einfach mal
so und wenn er gleich kommen da fahren
wir hinterher und dann gucken wir so was
passiert ich weiß auch nicht vielleicht
auch mega unspektakulär und das
schlimmste wäre wenn wir jetzt hier so
war dann einfach nach hause fährt aber
sie haben doch locker da ganz hinten
sind welche
drei hunde begrüßt du das
hey leute schaut euch mal dieses haus an
so was also wunder welche leute da ist
eine eingestiegen hatte hatte das guck
was sie sehen wollen wir den jetzt
einfach hinterher fahren ich warte mal
klar gemacht gehen zurück aber zurück
gedreht der 3
ich freue mich wenn weil da können sie
jetzt schon waren eigentlich sicher dass
willi habe als ob er davon ausgeht dass
jemand nicht
ich hab einfach der kann einfach von
links so gesehen ist der unterricht
rechts rechts hier nicht
wenn wir das ist halt
fährt so langsam also die bayern ihn auf
jeden fall wo wir fahren jetzt also ich
will jetzt nicht mehr ran fahren so
er denke ich auch so dass für das filmen
im auto ihr was schützt denn die albaner
oder hast du das gesehen
ich denke mal so gegen 30 35 ich hab den
ja gar nicht gesehen und jetzt kommt
auch noch ein trecker nationalrats an
jetzt ist er schon wieder weg
also fahren jetzt zumindest relativ wir
in richtigen stadt so ein dummer eis
waren vor uns
der link links aber ich sehe für uns
sind drei autos war jenes
verhängnisvollen ist wenig da kommst du
voraus
du kannst du hast gerade von polen hier
für uns ist
[Musik]
und mal ganz ehrlich wird euch schnell
weg
das sind aber diese videos scheimann
jetzt haben wir dann verlor ich habe
wenn er geradeaus fährt
ich kann mich da ja auch da muss ja da
hinten rauskommt jetzt hier hochfahren
also wird ganz viel glück
wir finden aber ich muss hier rechts
runter also er kann nur da hinten kommt
der ganze kreuzung praktisch wenn man
dann wieder ausführen er ist und da kann
er nur geradeaus fahren links oder
rechts oben
[Musik]
das gute ist fährt nicht schnell aber er
ist jetzt wenn die ampel jetzt mit die
grünen bleibt er ist es gesehen ich
machen soll ich jetzt einfach hier
rechts jahren da einfach erreichen macht
[Musik]
aber ich möchte das unauffällig irgendwo
parken ich hätte zu 100000 euro gewettet
dass das dass das jetzt bauen wir
entweder das video neu starten müssen
die jetzt gemachten kann
sollten hier der frau recht wenig davon
dass sie warten bis aus dem auto geht es
hinein packen jetzt
wartemann kamera unter mache mir jetzt
anders kommen
die von rechts grenze wo mir einfach
einsehen
[Musik]
und was das denn hiermit ich dass dies
sicherlich nicht
muss man hier gewissen weg was man da
den weg lang die coole schule liegt dann
ist ja ich möchte das team kommen
also höre ich für dieses schlechte filme
aber ich kann sich besser
da geht es in die andere richtung oder
der ist weg gegangen und hat hier
irgendwo irgendwas geworden so weiter
vorn
es war heute hier hatten wir sind es
musste gewesen sei aber hier so nicht
ein babyfoto am klatschen
hier drin bist du dumm vielleicht ist
der pilzesammler oder so kann auch sein
ich meine das wird das begründen heißt
wir haben im auto schon so gedacht so
man macht sich ja dann so das heftigste
aus also ich sage der hat hier pilze
gesammelt oder so was anderes macht ja
keinen sinn gemeint dann wünscht man
sein auto geguckt fahrzeug
leute leute wie geht es schnell
also leute wir gehen jetzt einfach
zurück aber um ehrlich zu sein ich habe
jetzt keine ahnung was also ich denke
mir immer noch etwas mehr machen
menschen so oder weiß man ja da ist weg
also sollten wir sind jetzt wieder im
auto natürlich ist jetzt nichts über ist
klassisch passiert so aber ich habe
trotzdem oder ich frage mich immer noch
was also keine ahnung hast du da gemacht
hat ich habe ja gesagt also meine
theorie andere ist bild zusammen oder
was man ja auch noch eingefallen ist
vielleicht musste halt so proben vom
boden also es gibt wirklich das gibt es
wirklich dass sie so doch dass diese
probleme von diesen verschiedenen böden
irgendwie und dann halt gucken wie das
öko system nicht verändert und so weil
sie jetzt kein vorurteil oder sonst was
aber jetzt nicht gehört jetzt der sei
aber bei uns um gingcom ist heute
eigentlich relativ normal auswahl mit
ich denke das kann sein das ist ein
drogendealer ist ja mal so eine
reportage gesehen in berlin machen die
dass er die verstecken große mengen ich
verbuddeln das und dann kommt irgendwann
ein anderer zu einer anderen zeit und
holt das ist ja das geschah nicht keine
ahnung ihr könnt ihr eure theorie in die
kommentare schreiben
ansonsten war es wird im video ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen kanal ab und wenn
wir das noch mal machen soll man könnte
es ja noch mal machen
man könnte ja natürlich ich glaube bis
man jemanden hat der irgendwie komisch
sagt macht also da muss man auch glück
haben ja aber der war schon mal nicht
schlecht aber einig dass kassel bei dem
war eigentlich das witzige an den wieder